so in this talk today I want to speak
about how could we free the classroom
from the
finds of its walls how could we design a
classroom which gets better as more
people participate how could we create a
global classroom and in doing so I want
to take what we know about how people
learn in in-person classroom especially
in creative domains and build
computational systems that scale out
these techniques to tens of thousands of
people so over the last few years you've
seen how millions of students have
enrolled in massive online classes and
to me what this joint interest shows
about all is this enormous thirst for
knowledge and colleges and universities
have been meeting the needs
traditionally of the college demographic
but what we see with these new online
classes is that the college demographic
is just a tiny sliver of the population
that's interested in learning this these
are the results from a large class cross
class survey in for online classes with
aren't sixty thousand participants and
you see that only a third of the
participants in these online classes
call themselves students and the rest of
them say I'm not a student right so who
are these people so if you look at a
class enrollment data you see that only
twenty percent of students say in the
HCI online class are traditional
students and the vast majority of them
are students we would not expect to see
in an in-person college classroom so now
that we have the means to reach this
enormously broader learner population
the question to me is how could we teach
these tens of thousands of new learners
effectively and today in the stock I'm
going to argue that there are three
ingredients to teaching that we need to
scale to this massive online world and
these are three ingredients that we see
consistently across engineering art
design and other domains they're also
really hard to scale because these are
teaching processes which rely on
personal interactions between people
that have been fostered by staff so here
is the first of those three interactions
it's feedback on open-ended work whether
you are in an art class and you create
hundreds and hundreds of sketches or
you're learning how to program by
writing your own code in an intro
programming class the crucial aspect to
doing open-ended work is getting
feedback on such work
however giving feedback requires
expertise and this is a task that has
fallen traditionally to staff this
doesn't scale to the online world for
example if you just do what we do in the
in-person class here at Stanford with
the cs 106 a class for example we would
spend 30 minutes per student per week
giving them feedback with a small online
class of 5,000 students this would take
around three and a half percent months
of effort each week so that's the first
ingredient that I believe in you to
scale second we need to scale
interactions with peers who have diverse
perspectives this could take for example
the form of a Model United Nations or it
could take the form of a design critique
on in person design class what's central
to both of these is that students are
speaking with other people who have
opinions and perspectives that are
different from their own now students
don't go around making friends with
people who they disagree with right so
staff have fostered these interactions
in the in-person road how do you scale
out the scaffolding to the online world
for the last in teaching process I want
to go back to the sketch I showed you a
couple slides ago after nearly 200
revisions it became Pablo Picasso's
famous painting the muzzle sylvania what
Picasso's example shows is the central
importance of revision to mastery our
revision requires meaningful feedback
how do you provide meaningful feedback
that requires expertise to tens of
thousands of people online so these are
the three these are the three learning
processes that I think we need to scale
to the online world and in the rest of
my talk today I'm going to describe
three systems that are well as part of
my dissertation they target each of
these three teaching process in general
my approach to building of these systems
is to take what we know about how people
learn in the in-person world essentially
take what we know from learning tyrion
from psychology and create computational
systems that scale these techniques to
thousands of students using techniques
from human centered design and social
computing all of these systems that I'm
describing to you today have invalidated
scale as
mentioned run nearly 40 randomized
controlled experiments which look at a
variety of different aspects of learning
in the online classroom of course some
of these experiments ended up giving the
results that we expected those are in
green a large fraction of them had
results which surprised us and where the
opposite of what we expected those are
in red today in the stock I'm only going
to describe to you the results of 40
well it doesn't also these 40
experiments and those were run in
classes start by these universities so
voila is building these systems for the
large online world it became apparent
that the teaching processes that scale
to tens of thousands of people are also
valuable in the in-person context sew in
the tail end of my talk I'll describe
how some professors are using these
tools in in-person classes at these
universities so the first system I want
to describe to you today is one on
global peer assessment and the impetus
for the system came about around three
years ago when Daphne Koller who is then
a colleague at Stanford and now of
course co2 Coursera came to a squat
climber my advisor and I and said let's
take the introductory HCI class that you
run at Stanford and open it up so that
anybody on the Internet can enroll in it
and while we thought through the
challenges of doings for transforming
instruction especially lectures to an
online format is relatively
straightforward but transforming
assessment is a lot more challenging at
the time we started most online classes
had either simple multiple-choice type
of questions or they had completely
automated assessments so if you are in a
programming language or machine learning
class you'd write a piece of code you
would upload it to a server the server
would then run either automated test or
static analysis on your code and then it
would return to you a report which told
you what you did right and what you did
wrong now this works well if you have a
programmatic understanding of what
students wrote and what quality means
but how does this work for a much more
open-ended task for example this is a
typical HCI
assignment in this in this example a
student is creating a storyboard which
shows how someone might use a prototype
he plans to build in this case for
before booking a doctor's appointment
now if you want to assess this kind of
work you first have to parse the
storyboard but also you need real world
common sense knowledge for example you
need to know that people want to meet
their doctors as soon as possible so
including such real-world knowledge into
completely automated systems has been a
long-standing challenge but humans
through their many years of experience
have encoded this knowledge and so the
inside that our assessment system and
bodies is to simply ask students in the
classroom to us as each other's work
it's somewhat a trivial insight that the
number of students in a class scales
with the size of the classroom but
covered with this trivial insight is a
problem and is that students are in your
class because they're trying to learn
they don't have the expertise the
teachers bring to the table when they're
trying to assess the student work so the
inside that are that that the system
that we built embodies is one of
scaffold and micro expertise essentially
our hypothesis was that even though
students lack the broad expertise of
teachers in a constrained setting they
can follow instruction instructor or
articulated guidelines and assess like
instructor success so be honest I think
the state of building large-scale
scaffolded systems is still in its
infancy and in some sense what we're
looking for are these design patterns
which work at large scale and robustly
so we considered a number of design
patterns let me show you one in this
case we gave students a rubric which
told them how instructors would assess a
particular piece of student work and
then we asked him to use this rubric to
look at five other people five other
classmates work the user rubric assessed
with their classmates and and a
student's grade was the aggregate grade
of the grades that they're their peers
assigned them we also added a second
step where we asked Jones to self-assess
use the same rubric and look at their
own work and necessity now if you if the
system works well then both of these
measures would correlate perfectly
everyone would use the same quality
standard and therefore wait let me first
show you how how it looks in an
interface so here you go this is the
storyboard and this is the rubric that
the instructor provided students choose
a score they add a few comments if which
are optional okay so if if this work
perfectly then the students self grade
and the grades that other students gave
them would correlate perfectly so on
this chart I want to show you how well
the correlated and here it is right on
the x axis of this chart is at the grade
students gave themselves on the y-axis
is a great that other people gave them
and this is actual data this is not a
matrix in which I'm going to plot the
data so you can see that there's very
minimal correlation this was a design
pattern which needs some work okay so
what could we do we added a training
step so in this case what we did was we
asked instructors to assess a small
fraction of the submissions in the
classroom and KD submissions to students
gave them the rubric that instructors
used but did not tell them what grades
instructors gave each submission then
students created these submissions
independently and they got feedback as
to whether they were grading too high or
too low so there they could self-correct
students went through a number of these
submissions and then we tacked on the
rest of our design pattern there to show
you before the assessor number of the
classmates and reassess themselves okay
here's how well this works I showed you
before the case with no training we try
it in a different class now with
training and we see much better
correlation now the question so now that
it seems that we have much better
correlation the next question we asked
is our students giving each other
assessments which compared with stuff
essentially how well do staff instrument
grades correlate and in order to find
out what we did was we inserted a
previously staff created submission in
every
grading pool students do not see the
submission differently from any other
submission that your grading but this
gives us a data set of a small number of
staff assist submissions with a large
number of student assessments now we can
run a bootstrap simulation which takes a
small subset of each student assessment
small subset of the assessments for each
student submission and then compare this
the medium grade from there to the staff
grade by running those bootstrap
simulation multiple times we can get a
robust estimate of how well student
creates correlated staff rates so we ran
such a simulation and i'm going to show
you the results for this pass/fail class
the two outcomes that we care about in
this class I'll be passing the right
students and are we not passing the
right students right so here is the
first case these are students who would
not have passed if they were graded by
staff and you can see that 99.3 percent
of the time they were not passed when
they were graded by their classmates the
second question we might ask is would
would you earn a certificate with purity
rating if you would have earned it a
staff it graded you and here you see
that nice one point eight percent of the
time students do get the certificates
that you deserve now there's a 2.2%
failure rate here and it sounds like a
small percentage but of course because
it's a large number of students it's
still as a large number of people who
are affected so I'm not going to
describe other work that we've done in
order to improve this number and we can
get this number down with some iterative
improvements to this process what I will
want to what I do want to show you is
the distribution of how peers and staff
rate each submission so this is a
histogram and on the x-axis is the
difference between them the median grade
that peers gave a particular student
submission and the staff grade so also I
put these two red lines here because if
you ask that if you ask two staff
members to create the same submission
they don't always agree this is as you
would expect because this open-ended
work on average the difference between
staff was six point seven percent of the
total grade
the class of the ugliest island so we
see that with your rating forty-seven
percent of student submissions have
grades within this staff radiation and
you see that around sixty-five percent
of them have grades which are twice the
staff variation so it seems to work well
for a pass/fail class but there are
obviously limitations one of them is a
pretty fundamental limitation we are
asking students to assess each other
using a rubric now if you have
particularly creative work that falls
outside the box then yes your classmates
may not know how to assess it here is
one student who put it rather low
country so in response to do student
comments like this we made a simple
change which is we added a checkbox at
the very end of our submission process
but said this was an out-of-the-box
submission so we could know both how how
well the rubric worked and how we could
improve it so as I mentioned before we
this this this was a large scale for
your assessment process we piloted it in
Scotts online HCI class and since then
it's been used in more than 100
different classes and more than 100,000
students have submitted and rated each
other's work using the system one
consistent theme that we see across all
of these classes is how students find
each other's work to be inspiring for
example here is a student here here are
two examples from an introduction to art
class this is one particular assignment
and on the left you see a painting of
the Northern Lights from Norway and on
the right is this installation art from
Armenia both of which were student
submissions in the same assignment in
this class often when people ask you and
saw something like this they would say I
have never seen something like that in
real life now this is one of the
greatest benefits of online global
classes but we also see a downside so
students were blind to who they were
grading but we saw that students often
gave grades
which are a little lower to students
from different countries this this graph
shows you that if you are from a
different country you would be rated
around four percent lower then if you
are in the same country as your pure
Assessor as as with all results in this
in the stock is significant at the point
of eye level so we see here that global
diversity can be both a huge asset as
well as a huge risk so what this
suggests to us is that if we can
structure these fear interactions
carefully we can make a diversity more
of an asset and less of a risk and speak
about it in the next section of my talk
but I quickly wanted to summarize the
contributions from this global peer
assessment system and we saw that we can
scale assessment through scaffold at
micro expertise and assessment can be
both accurate as well as inspiration now
we wanted i said i'll talk about global
diversity being both an asset in the
risk and to do that i want to describe
the second part of my dissertation a
system called talk about this is a
system which uses diversity as a design
opportunity in particular it creates
diverse discussions for students from
around the world so by care about
diversity in this particular system we
are looking at two primary benefits of
diversity first of all there are the
informational benefits when students
from around the world talk to each other
you get exposed to a different
educational system different ways of
thinking as well as different cultural
values in addition to this information
again you also have a cognitive gain
when students speak to each other who
are when students speak to similar
others they may think in a passive and
automatic mode of thinking but by
speaking to people who are unlike you
you're forced to engage in a more active
and effort phone manner of thinking
which ultimately we hope will lead you
to question your assumptions and learn
better now these are great benefits of
diversity and online classes are a great
opportunity to leverage these benefits
here is aggregated geoip data from
around half a million students in four
different classes and you can see that
people in online classes are enrolling
from a crossword
so there's an almost even distribution
from different parts of the world here
now even though there's this great
opportunity most students don't get to
see any of these benefits of diversity
even when students do engage with each
other on the forums we often see posts
like this where students are looking for
others were just like themselves who's
think similarly or speak the same
language now this isn't a new problem
even in the in-person classroom teachers
have had to foster diverse interactions
either by creating for example cross
ability project teens or say cross
background are dumb dorm rooms so the
question to me is how do we create the
online equivalent of the multicultural
dorm room and our answer is the system
called talked about which I described to
you right away so talk alot is a system
where students who are enrolled in an
online class get to pick a time when
they are willing to speak with
classmates from around the world when
you pick a time and arrive for the
discussion talk about automatically
finds you four or five other people to
speak with and and you can engage in a
discussion with diverse classmates from
around the world on a system built on
top Google Hangouts now it's important
here that students get to pick a time of
their convenience because it showed you
before these are students who may have
full time jobs but it's also the case
here that students don't get to pick
whom they speak with so this allows talk
about to algorithmically assign students
to groups in particular we use a very
greedy a very simple greedy algorithm
which assigns each student to one of
many parallel groups we try and optimize
for the diversity in each group in this
case we use very simple metrics of
diversity in particular we look at
geographical location that is the
location of residence and we look at
gender different instructors may want
different kinds of diversity in the
classroom so we allow instructors to
think how much they want to wait either
geography or gender to balance see the
geography or gender
okay so and now i want to show you how
students participate in these
discussions we conducted many many
interviews with students who
participated in these global discussions
here is one of them this is a student
his name is Lex he lives in Australia
and he took part in the organizational
analysis class as he speaks you can see
how he gets to speak with people from
different parts of the world who are
different organizational experience it's
very flexible you get people from you
green from India from Swiss from South
Africa they're coming all together in a
very yeah open way the first time it was
also a lady from Australia and she was
working in the gambling industry she was
Harry evoked if a very well she was very
very bright I was this guy from China as
well it was he worked in Geneva for the
United Nations completely over
frustrated by bureaucracy when you meet
all those people for over the whole
world and coming together and discussing
the same theory said that's really
excited right so lots and lots of
students I experiences just like Lex in
fact if you look at the discussion data
you see that on average the median
number or rather the median number of
countries represented in a six-person
discussion group is five and the median
distance between participants is larger
than their distance between new york and
london we also see that students discuss
with their classmates much longer than
we asked them to so instructors created
discussion agendas which is supposed to
fit a discussion of 30 minutes let's
this green line here and you see that
most students speak for much longer the
median duration was 58 minutes so we
conducted interviews and participated in
some of these discussions to find out
what is happening and one common reason
was that instructors would often tell
students you can take from one of two
discussion topics and students would
then pick the first discussion topic
a group and then they are take the
second discussion topic as a group and
continue their discussions all right so
so it seems like students seem to like
these discussions I would like to know
if evaluate better participating in
these discussions helps in particular I
want to look at two questions that's
participating in a global discussion
health and as a diversity in
participants improve the benefits of of
participation okay to find out the
answer to the first question we ran a
controlled experiment in the irrational
behavior class this had around a
thousand students and students in this
class when I signed up for talk about
we're assigned to one of two
between-subjects conditions in the
waitlist condition students were told
talk about isn't ready for you yet come
back for weeks later which was the
halfway point in the class the other
half of the class who signed up for talk
about was allowed to discuss our
participate in discussions from the
first week of class so this creates
experimental setup where half the
students but equally motivated have been
prevented from participating in
discussions so we can control for the
back for the effects of motivation so to
analyze the results we ran an
intention-to-treat analysis oops sorry a
favor tell you one important thing the
they depended measure that we looked at
in this class in this experiment was the
total course created students hired at
the end of this class so here the
results we're at an intention-to-treat
analysis for looking at our results and
we see that students were assigned to
the discussion condition scored
approximately six percent higher the
instruments were assigned to the
weightless condition so this could be
for example because you're spending more
time thinking about class topics while
they were participating in discussions
so we now ask does the diversity in
participants improve the benefits of
participation and to find out again we
run a controlled experiment this time in
a social psychology class with around
2,500 students and this was a quasi
experiment instead of assigning students
greedily to the most diverse group
available we assign students the first
available group now this creates a
condition where some students are
assigned to more diverse discussions and
others who are assigned to less do
versus questions
as the measure of as a dependent measure
in this experiment we looked at the
grade in the final exam which occurred a
week after students participated in
these discussions because this
discussion happened at a tail end of
class we controlled for prior
performance in the class as one of our
variables in our in our regression model
okay so let me show you the results on
this chart on the y-axis is the
difference between the average grade the
average difference the difference
between the average grade of students
who are assigned to the most diverse
discussion group and the least diverse
discussion group and in the social
psychology class we see that students
scientist the most diverse discussion
group had grade situated to and a half
percent higher than students assigned to
least reverse discussion group these
these are differences caused simply by
assigning students to different groups
the everybody had the same agenda for
discussion for example we repeated this
experiment in the organizational
analysis class and we saw that students
stood around three and a half percent
better on each weekly quiz the week they
participated in a discussion so we see
here that there that discussion
participating in discussions helps we
also see that the diversity amongst
participants in a discussion improves
these benefits while as while we're
deploying these systems we got several
emails from students I want to show you
one of them because it I think
highlights an important issue for future
work this is my jamel she emailed me
from Egypt last year and this was when
he had the chaos and the uprisings in
the riots in Egypt and she was trying to
participate in this talk about
discussion now you can see that she
couldn't and we rescheduled our
discussion to help her out but I think
there's an important point for future
researchers to make sure that the
systems that we will provide equitable
access to students from around the world
still even with the systems that we have
today students are already using talked
about as a springboard to create global
friendships in a post discussion survey
across nine classes we asked students
did you share contact information with
the rest of your discussion group
remember these are discussion partners
were assigned by an algorithm so they
did not know who they will be speaking
with you find that around forty seven
percent of
it's actually shared information such as
email in some classes this happened in
owning majority of the time for example
in the International Women's Health and
Human Rights class we conducted follow
ons to find out why this was so and a
common reason was because students
wanted to create a strong support
network so that they could change the
status quo so far we've had more than
5,000 students use talked about in the
last year and they've discussed a wide
variety of topics one way students have
contributed back to the system is by
translating it into different languages
such as French Spanish and there's one
more now we're done forgot I forgot
anyway so alright so so to summarize in
this section at talk about as a system
which uses diversity as a design
opportunity and create small group
discussions at a globally diverse it
improves not just course grades but it
also creates these new opportunities to
form global friendships before I move on
I wanted to thank Julia who's here she
helped majorly in this project and he's
not at Coursera so clearly she's doing
other things as well all right so and
then in the last section of my talk
today I want to speak about using scale
as a design opportunity and in
particular I want to describe the system
called pure studio but if we go back to
the very start of my talk I spoke about
how revision is central to mastery here
is James Dyson who speaks about how it
took him 15 years of his life and more
than 5,000 prototypes to create the
cyclone vacuum cleaner now examples like
James license speak about how important
it is to iterate on design other
researchers for example this is Anders
Ericsson who speaks about deliberate
practice also talks about the importance
of religion and more importantly here
the importance of giving and receiving
immediate feedback on under under work
that you've created this says for
example soon should receive immediate
and formative feedback knowledge your
results as they as the practice
repeatedly
now there are some classroom techniques
which have created systems for revision
and for public display of work the
probably the most well-known is the
design studio this a place where
students exhibit the ongoing work and
they can get feedback from both peers
and from experts on on such work but the
design studio is limited by geography it
can only accommodate so many people what
if instead we want to create a massive
online studio where anybody on the
internet would enroll and participate in
particular our goal here is to create a
system which provides students on demand
an immediate feedback on open-ended work
at any time of day the system will be
cleared called pure studio and here's
how it works students can use pure
studio to get feedback on open-ended
work in classrooms they can submit a
draft for feedback give feedback to two
other classmates on similar work and
immediately thereafter get feedback on
their own work they can use this
feedback to revise their work any number
of times until they're happy with it and
get some a different grades so one way
to bear this system is to simply take
part I described to you in the first
section of the stock on peer assessment
and flip a bit which allows students to
submit multiple times we could do that
but that has a problem and the problem
is I told you how assessment training is
crucial to accuracy but assessment
training also takes a lot of time for
example in an assignment which took
students or median of ten and a half
hours and HCI class students spent
around two hours learning how to assess
each other now this is a cost that we
might be willing to pay if we seek very
accurate assessments of final work but
maybe we don't want to pay this cost
when you're looking at draft work and
you're seeking early feedback so in
particular the research question that we
ask is how could we scaffold this notion
of micro expertise I spoke about in a
way that doesn't require an explicit
training step and the solution that we
came up with uses the idea of
contrasting cases and in particular so
perhaps I should explain for us with an
example so if you give me a glass of
wine
and ask me it should might describe this
glass of wine I'm going to tell you it
tastes like wine because I don't know
much about wine on the other hand if you
give me two different kinds of lines and
tells me chin might compare these two
glasses of wine then I can start telling
you one of them is more floral one of
the most fruit here the other one tastes
like pencil shavings things like that so
what does what's example shows us to
acknowledge like me comparing two
artifacts which is superficially similar
allows me to understand the deeper
non-super facial structure of each
artifact this is how pure studio
embodies this insight into an interface
this is a student work that peers are
asked to give feedback on as before we
augmented with the rubric which the
instructor provides in this case we also
augment it with an instructor curated
example of excellent work the way
students assets in pierce to do is to
compare student work to the instructor
provided example across the number of
dimensions then they mark off their
assessments on a rubric and which is
over here sorry yeah so we tried this
assessment process in a pilot in a small
in-person class and we found that on
average students the majority of
students and the staff disagree around
five point seven percent of the time so
this is accurate enough to give students
quick feedback without a explicit
training strap now the other part of
getting quick feedback is getting
someone to give you that feedback so how
do you recruit reviewers quickly in this
case the mass of an S of the online
class is a friend and in particular
Pierce to do use or do of recruitment
strategy when it detects that other
people are online it simply asks the
next student who comes online to review
your work in cases where we detect that
few people are online for example if you
are in a time zone where few people have
submitted work then we will start
recruiting reviewers for your email we
stop recruiting immediately after we've
recruited enough people
we tried this recruitment scheme a large
online class they're learning how to
learn class and here is how how quickly
students got feedback and the x-axis is
the time to the first review and you see
that a vast number of students got
feedback within 10 minutes the average
time sorry the median time to feedback
was 20 minutes in this class and less
than four percent of students had to
wait longer than 24 hours to get
feedback so here is the life of a median
student who is using pure studio they
create their essay for example in this
class by using this online editor they
submit this for feedback they give
feedback to two other students using the
interface I showed you earlier on
average that is 1 million students take
nine minutes to give each other feedback
so 18 minutes later they are done giving
feedback to other of the classmates they
wait two minutes and they get feedback
from there from their classmates on
their own work this is how that looks
now they can use this feedback a to
revise any number of times until they're
happy with their submission and then
they submitted for a grade so we built
the system and we were very happy with
the accuracy the feedback that students
had and we are happy with the time how
quickly how a student's guard the
feedback and then we discovered a
problem and the problem was that even
though feedback can be accurate it's not
always actionable and to illustrate I
want to show you this one example of a
student essay which a professional
teacher annotated this is an essay on
the Super Bowl and if you're in the back
you may not be able to see what the
student has written not just teachers
comments but you can see it's pretty
heavily Marta right so for example in
the first line the teacher says be more
precise be less already use a comma here
so looking at feedback like this you
might think this students work is nearly
complete all it needs is a few
grammatical fixes and then you look in
the margins and then you say it says you
need to do more research
so essentially this invalidates there as
to the comments of the teacher is made
because you have to toss away what
you've written and start over again what
you'd like instead is a system which
kill students the most actionable
feedback at any time during the process
and we know from feedback Theory some
things that could help for example we
know that feedback which use the
information and correctness what you've
done right and velocity which way you
should move and what you should do is is
very effective we also know that
feedback that is specific and is related
to your topic is a lot more relevant
than general truisms about how you
should do work now we can encode these
into an interface and in particular I
built a system which give students
real-time tips for as they're writing
comments for each other and it uses for
example logistic regression model which
predicts for example if the comments
that you're writing are topically
relevant to the student work it use
simple bag of word features and word
overlap tourism here okay so here's how
it looks like in practice here's a
rubric I showed you before and in this
rubric green means good and red means
needs work what we do here is compute a
score based on how you marked up the
rubric and then we make a suggestion for
you what you should say in this case we
say that this looks mostly good except
for this last part how do you improve it
if things didn't look quite as good we
would say what's the first thing your
suggest to improve this other students
might see prompts like be more specific
as to what the students should change if
we decide the dipping to pay so we had a
TA independently read the comments that
students road and you see that
eighty-one percent of student
submissions had feedback the TA rated as
actionable interestingly here students
rated their feedback to be actionable
much more frequently than T yesterday so
alright so here is here are some of the
changes that we see when we use a system
which provides real-time terps without
hence
students tended to focus mostly on the
author of the work and what they'd done
well so we saw engrams like I think you
are on the right track for example or I
would I I wish you good luck or even
bizarrely I hope you have a nice day
with tips on the other hand we found
that students tended to focus much more
on the work itself and how it could be
improved we saw words like I think you
should change something or any I think
you need to do something or your work
would improve by doing something of
course it doesn't work all the time
students are often stumped for what they
should tell people who are already very
good this is a real student comment for
example but overall we want to know if
the feedback that students give each
other helps them improve their work and
to find out we're on a between-subjects
experiment in the medical education
class taught here is transferred it used
well it had it had a hundred for
students who consented to be in this
experiment and it had three
between-subjects conditions the first
was a no early feedback condition where
students were not allowed to revise the
work this was the standard classroom
condition where you would do the best
work you could and you'd submitted
someone would then review your work and
then give you ask or think then we are
the second condition where students were
allowed to revise any number of times
but they would only get feedback 24
hours or later after the submitted so
I'm sorry exactly 24 hours after this
one middle and this control condition I
call it the enthusiastic ta condition so
the TST is up overnight and gives you
feedback in the last condition we had
students get feedback as quickly as
possible as quickly as the pure studio
system could provide them in this case
the median student got feedback in less
than an hour okay so when he looked at
the results you see that the early
feedback condition had grades which were
on average four and a half percent
higher than students who were not
allowed to revise so you can see here
the benefits of early early and fast
feed
on improvements and our course grades we
also found that students who guard early
feedback which was delayed by 24 hours
had grades which are statistically
indistinguishable from students who had
no opportunity to revise at all so this
is the enthusiastic ta condition
particular so but when we look at our
data one reason why you think this might
happen is because we students refer to
their reviewer comments much less
frequently when they get these comments
a day later so students have made up
their own made up the mind as to what
changes they want to make already and
reviewer comments don't really change
the plan we also see who this helps the
most on this chart I'm going to show you
a histogram with the grade on the y-axis
and the number of students on the x-axis
we are comparing the no revision no
early feedback condition with the fast
feedback and revision condition and you
see here that for the most part what's
happening is that oops the students are
benefiting the most as students who had
good work already so essentially what
fast feedback as implemented with your
studio is doing is it's converting good
work into great work by providing
students early feedback and an
opportunity to revise so this furious
system has been used in online classes
for example here or two of them on the
cursor and open EDX platform it's also
been used in multiple in-person classes
to assess a wide variety of work and in
in person classes we see instructor is
using fear studio as an opportunity for
early feedback the way it works is that
students the network and they get
feedback on the early drafts from the
classmates and the TA uses the pure
studio system to to give students grades
on the final work so with peers to do
you see a a system that uses scale as a
design opportunity to provide students
early and rapid feedback you also see
how it can create an opportunity for
in-person classes to offer students an
option arey that did not otherwise have
to get early feedback off
in less than two hours so i'll have been
building these systems that I described
in my talk today other researchers have
used some of the insights that we
embodied in these systems to for example
create better peer assessment systems to
create crowdsource quality control
algorithms and so on we've also seen how
many platforms have not include a peer
assessment as part of the standard
feature set for example now EDX has one
and Khan Academy has gone to both of
them use the train and then assess model
and and and very recently we see that
Coursera when it redesigned its peer
assessment system drew on several ideas
that we created in our peers to do all
right so this is what I've been doing so
far or the last few years a one way to
summarize this work is that you take of
you where you have learning which
transforms novices into experts and the
traditional way of doing this has been
through deliberate practice and revision
usually in the past this has been done
with the help of a coach and in the last
decade we have seen how tutoring systems
have enabled lots more students to have
the benefits of deliberate practice
through in domains such as mathematics
this talk shows you how you could use
how you could extend these benefits too
many more domains especially domains
which which requires students to engage
and create a work but all of this work
is along one dimension it is efficiency
in one dimension and this is dan
schwartz and his ideas which have
influenced me here so in the future one
thing i would like to do is to explore
this other dimension which is innovation
across domains and again this is this is
dan who is on my committee so in future
research one thing i would like to do is
to build systems to help students become
adaptive experts who are good at
learning how to learn and can do well
across domains i want to show you a few
examples of how
such systems might look for example
could we create systems which know what
students are doing in multiple different
classes as their learning and help them
synthesize this knowledge to both
transfer n and transfer out of each
domain using systems like Pierce to do
we have some understanding of what
students are doing in each class we
could build on this understanding to
help yours helps truer and synthesize
their ideas even further as yet another
provocation could we provide everybody
in the world a mentor on demand mentors
is really useful when you can find great
mentors I have been luckiest but many
others aren't could we create
computational systems which combine the
knowledge of many people together so
that people who need mentorship have a
have a coherent I'll have a coherent
system which provides some advanced and
finally let's talk about we saw the
enormous benefits of global diversity I
wanna ask could we create systems which
combine the benefits of global diversity
with local expertise from for example
that you see at your own workplace or
university so in closing I would like to
thank a number of people who helped me
enormously in here of course there's my
dissertation committee there Scott
Michael dan dan Candace thank you so
much I also had the fortune to work with
many great students there's Julia
Catherine and are actually here there's
there's others who couldn't be here and
they helped me enormously in my own
research as well as have done really
awesome stuff on their own and I've had
the opportunity to collaborate with
companies were big and small who really
poured this research forward oh I would
also like to thank the many professors
who have used our experimental systems
and who took a risk on us these are the
early adopters for some of the systems
that we built and of course all of the
students who i'm sure experienced both
the joys in the first three
shins of using a search system so i
would also finally like to thank my
friends who've been really wonderful and
everything they do and they'll supported
me and inspired me throughout my PhD
they have done both silly and amazing
things for example there's khabar here
who's wearing the berry and i believe a
kilt are you wearing a suit yeah here
not had a deal that whoever Defence
Force would how the other person were
killed and over a to this sorry yeah
okay alright so and finally I'd like to
thank my parents whose everyday
sacrifices at the reason why you should
I start alright so in closing this was a
talk in structuring peer interactions
for learning at scale and we see how you
could use k the diversity and other
properties of the online world to
benefit students and novel ways you can
also see how you can use these systems
to create new systems for both adaptive
expertise in the wild and for providing
students benefits at large scale I'd
love to take your questions now but if
you can't make it to the list of
questions please email me I'd love to
hear from you
yeah earlier than you talked about
country bias and peer assessment hungry
is that just limited resources that are
understanding sort of I've seems to like
staff writers on finding another country
with the students from all right so
unfortunately all of our stock traders
we're from the United States and we had
with we have very few data points sir so
we have for example 20-yard staff staff
readers I did not see a bias in those
ratings but I'm sure that you know if
you scale it out then we might see
smaller biases that we might have missed
with 20 people re apologizing have
already asked you this informally so you
showed this as she mentioned this
country bias in the thread Kirby talk a
mini talked about talked about which
allows hills from different countries
interact with each other I was wondering
if you looked at the country bias just
for the subset of people who engaged in
time to see the one away no actually it
happened because we haven't had so the
data that we have doesn't allow us to
correlate across activities we only have
summary data for some of these classes
so I don't have the answer that question
but that is something that we certainly
should see and if for example you use
pure studio and talk about together then
we can collect a lot more data about
your behavior so yeah if she talks a lot
of how how to help students to learn
better and a little bit about how
students can help learn to evaluate
other people better with rubrics ever
thought about other improvements you can
make to teaching people to become better
teachers through the more kinds of
methods yes oh yes one has yes when
works with Scott and I at UC San Diego
and she's been looking at how you can
have instructors look at examples of
work that other instructors stood and
see what works well and what works
poorly so I think one problem that we
have is that we don't know the best
practices yet so we are sort of
discovering them as we go so I think
what Yasmin is
trying to do in our work is to say but
we don't know what works yet but we have
examples of things that work and things
that don't so by contrasting some of
them maybe instructors can find insights
for their own domains so yeah I don't
have numbers to share yeah yeah yeah um
for it you need to mess was like a peer
assessment that you can sort of check a
box like those if um the work was kind
of outside of the box then you can check
last night yeah this objection work or
the pure studio when you're comparing it
to like sort of an idealized right for
not an ideal version of it in sort of
making those sites comparisons what do
you do for exceptional work in that case
so in those cases we have a hostage says
this is our the box right so being able
to say that this is out of the box i
think is independent of being able to
compare it with excellent across
dimensions so so we have that in both
cases other questions alright hey no far
did you have anyone knowing the students
in the classes like how they felt about
all these things at you showed a couple
emails by wondering if there was another
way yes we did interview a lot of people
who use talked about for example and I
showed you one of those the so what we
have seen with with Pierce to do what
what he asked man has seen because she's
done these interviews with Pierce to do
in in-person classes is that students
often have this question as to shouldn't
the instructor be doing the grading
right so there's that sort of fear as to
why are my classmates doing it in
practice so I if you if you look at how
well students and students and
instructors assess students get very
very close to instructors on the on the
sum total grade so I think there is a
question of how do you change student
perceptions to make them see the
benefits of assessing each other so
yeah so that's what a data point does it
answer your question yeah do you think
the ability to assess in in one domain
transfer where'd you have it in here so
so you know you're training in one class
yeah yeah do you start a higher level on
the next ah I don't know that's a great
question to find out yeah I I let you
know Rob yeah oh yes hi um I'm wondering
if you if you would agree that the
feedback that students get from their
peers the feedback you showed isn't it
very very one-dimensional and very cool
quantifiable and quantitative and not
very qualitative because I understand
that the grades they gave in the passing
rates may be very similar to what
professors would give them but in terms
of part of feedback and great we can't
expect someone who's trained to to go
for two hours to be at the level of
someone who you know what's cool for it
yeah so so I think there's yeah you're
right you can in isolation right so so I
think what what you have and you have
assessment by your classmates is that
you can have multiple assessments for
your same work right so if I show
something to Scott he can give me one
opinion but if i should show something
to my classmates i can get three
different opinions sometimes having
multiple perspectives was helpful in a
very early version of pure studio we did
not identify whether the commenter was
student or staff and actually turned out
that the students had higher rated
comments unhelpful pneus then the staff
comments hatch so I I think there is
there's multiple other factors at play
for example professors have lesser time
than your classmates to and have been
thinking about that assignment probably
less than you have in the last few
months I'm sorry last few days so it's
not always that you would get better
feedback if you ask your professors yeah
refer to things yeah one of the
instructor shows an example for Pierce
duty of the screenshot like the best
thing was someone talking about learning
elvish ahh that wasn't the best pain
that little tainted eggs are perfect
okay yeah everything I wanted nervously
look five percent or something of the
pure studio when you look at history of
how long people talking was almost like
three out yeah and if you hadn't eaten
without butter qualitative what was
going on there my initial interpretation
would be well this basically becomes
like a dorm hallway conversation guy
like I guess run leading and I'm curious
again the soapbox hot song would be what
is the sort of dorm hallway and what
does that future look like for education
at scale right now it sort of looked
like forums and you're starting to get
towards something where maybe killer
actually talking to each other face to
face split where might that go right so
so actually the three other thing I
think Julia would would know better
because she she once discovered that we
had this test widget so people could
test their hangout set up and so people
would hang out at the Hangout set up to
just chat with other people so that is
one place where you would see those
three hours coming in right so the as to
what is the hallway discussion I
actually think that one way of looking
at it is to look at how students are
using mobile phones already with pure
studio if you look at the emails that we
send out more than half the emails are
open on a mobile device so we tell
people your work has been reviewed and I
don't fifty-six percent of the time
they're looking at it on their phone
alright so so I think being able to have
this semi synchronous conversation using
mobile devices might be the right right
way to go so yeah back um when you have
subjects that don't assert themselves to
percentage grading or letter grades as
understand how do you how do you
anticipate a long post a lot of your
data is obviously it's very concrete and
you know it's percentages so how do you
how do you anticipate being able to
expand its subjects that don't really
work well traditional breaks right so so
I think you're pretty is right in the
sign says the systems that I described
to you today use a particular rubric
based approach to to how they do
assessment right and when you have a
rubric based approach you need to be
able to make rubric for one right so so
you're right there I think the one thing
that you could extend this work to see
is what you want is the ability to
create this scaffold at micro expertise
right so if you can do that without
having to use a rubric for example if
you are trying to critique someone's
dance form and you think that a rubric
is the wrong way to go if you can show
people say different kinds of dance
moves and say this is a good balance
dance move this is a bad one and being
able to tell those apart if you can
create that micro expertise then you
might be able to still use some of the
insights that these systems have
you